you may realize maybe you added a few
extra pounds during the pandemic
you're not alone the so-called
quarantined 15 has been a struggle for
many at home for months
and in a special report victoria saha
has the reasons behind the weight gain
during that year and came up with
really so many uncertainties so i've got
some of my smaller
sixes and my eights
that i kept because i know that i'm on a
mission
i'm going to get back in them now that
life is starting to look a little normal
mary rodina has one goal
lose the weight she gained during the
pandemic it just kind of
spiraled out of control for her it
wasn't long before she realized
she packed on 20 pounds being able to
work out and get those endorphins out
and get that stress out
also helps and so you know turning to
the comfort food
to replace that really made a difference
and having her work space be just a few
feet away from her kitchen
also didn't help when it came to boredom
she snacked and she baked i would like
bring in
all kinds of things scones i bought
professional scone pan
um professional baking cups
dr dipali kishap has seen patients that
have gained up to 30 pounds
diet stress abnormal sleep patterns all
of these combined
cause weight gain and which is what we
saw last year during covet
the stress of what was happening around
us was driving people to turn to food
or alcohol i saw high levels of insulin
in a lot of these people i saw
abnormal cholesterol high level of
total cholesterol or we call ldl which
is the bad cholesterol people call it i
saw that
the blood sugars have been going up on
the other hand there are people like
jessica hutchings
so my goal was not about
a physical number on the scale it was
more of a
how do i feel am i going to stay strong
am i going to be able to take care of my
child
and and how am i going to feel my best
the new mom had just given birth three
months before the pandemic hit
she made sure to stay active we ended up
buying bikes my husband and i with a car
seat on the back
and taking kind of family bike rides and
things
and getting creative using her son
elliott as a weight
while working out hutchings says
during the pandemic the only thing she
was able to control was how she felt
working out and getting out and walking
and getting fresh air like that was just
really important
victoria saha 8 news now